تعود هذه الصور الى العام 2015 خلال
محاكمه سيف الاسلام القذافي في العاصمه
الليبيه طرابلس في الصف الخلفي الى اليمين
يجلس بوجي لمحمد مسعود عميل سابق في
الاستخبارات الليبيه في 2020 اتهمته
السلطات الامريكيه بتصنيع القنبله التي
استخدمت باعتداء لوكربي وعلى مدى سنوات
بقيا مكان واحتجازه في ليبيا غير معلومه
الا ان عائلته قالت في منتصف الشهر الماضي
انه خططف من المنزل في طرابلس من قبل جهه
مجهوله والان تؤكد وزاره العدل الامريكيه
انه صار في قبضتها بحسب المحكمه الامريكيه
بعجين محمد مسعود خبير في صنع القنابل
انضم في سبعينيات الى جهاز المخابرات
الليبي وشارك في عده عمليات خارجه ليبيا
توقفه الان ياتي قبيل ايام على احياء ذكرى
الرابعه والثلاثين لتفجير الطائره التابعه
لشركه بان امريكا
معظمهم امريكيون وكان الحادث سب يعني عزله
نظام القذافي وتصاعد التوتر بين ليبيا
والولايات المتحده في عهد الرئيس الامريكي
جورج بوش الابن يوجيهت للتهامات
لدبلوماسيين الليبيين بارتكاب الاعتداء
وارينا احدهما فقط وهو عبد الباسط مجروحي
لكنه اعيد الى ليبيا بسبب مرض عضال يفارق
الحياه في 2012 وكان نظام معمر القذافي قد
اقر في 2003 بمسؤوليته عن التفجير وقبل
بتسويه دفع في اطارها اكثر من مليار دولار
كعويضات لاسر الضحايا